hey crazies whenever someone starts
talking about an expanding universe
there's always at least one person
asking this what is it expanding into
okay we'll tackle this but I'm not sure
you're going to like the answer demo
time let's say you have a balloon with
some little thingies attached these
represent galactic super clusters which
contain tens of thousands of galaxies
yes super clusters we don't see the
expansion on scales any smaller than
that because other forces like gravity
are strong enough to hold things
together in spite of the expansion
second to the man and galaxies alright
back to the balloon
these represent galactic super clusters
whereas the balloon itself represents
space if you blow air into the balloon
it expands carrying the super clusters
with it
they got farther apart without having to
do any actual moving in space
pretty cool huh well hold on a sec there
are a few problems with this demo first
we're representing our three-dimensional
space on a two-dimensional balloon syrup
the balloon demo is one dimension short
so it really only represents a slice or
cross section of the universe but then
again we drop from 3d to 1d in
space-time diagrams all the time and
nobody questions it the second problem
is the expanding balloon has curvature
positive curvature you can see it's
finite and have no edges however we said
in the last video that all evidence
suggests we live in a very flat zero
curvature universe and if it's simple an
infinite universe if that's the case
this balloon is a terrible model on top
of that the fact that it's only a model
can be misleading this balloon is any
room full of air and all sorts of other
stuff there's a space it expands into
but none of that applies to the universe
remember the entire universe is
everything even if the universe was
finite like that balloon the balloon is
all that there is there is no room no
air no person blowing that air just the
balloon so if that's the universe it's
not expanding into anything there is
nothing outside it now
empty space literally nothing
nothingness can be difficult to imagine
for a lot of people but your only other
option is an infinite universe and that
comes with its own problem you might
wonder how the universe could have gone
from a microscopic size to infinite size
in a finite amount of time well it
couldn't have if the universe is
infinite then it always was for all
measureable time
what no for real while it is true that
everything we can see was at one time
the size of a microscopic speck
everything we can see is just our
observable universe not the entire
universe and if the universe is infinite
it solves our nothingness issue because
the universe can just expand into itself
as space stretches we get more and more
space but if space is infinite
that's just more and more infinity when
you run the clock in Reverse a similar
thing happens at space contracts you
just have less and less infinity but
infinity is infinity no matter how small
infinity is so weird there's also no
reason to assume that our observable
part is anything special no matter where
you are in this infinite universe you'll
see an observable part that's about the
same size with you at the center further
into the past that bubble was a lot
smaller denser and hotter but that was
true everywhere in an infinite universe
there is no edge there is no center and
the Big Bang happened everywhere it's
kind of bothers me a little if the
universe is infinite and nowhere is
special does that mean there are an
infinity of needs somewhere out there
beyond the cosmic horizon am I wasting
my time cloning when I should just be
inventing faster than light travel I
didn't realize I was going to get to be
on camera if there are infinite
possibilities why does it all look the
same
what do you think are there infinite
copies of all of us let me know in the
comments thanks for liking and sharing
this video don't forget to subscribe
just like to keep up with us and until
next time remember it's okay to create
hey this is where I normally do comment
responses from the previous video but
they were so good I just turned them
into this entire video
don't worry well some Lancer questions
from this video in the next Oh
and Joey green i'll ask whatever science
questions like this well please all
right crazy thanks for watching
[Music]